most of our favorite characters from the
original Seven Deadly Sins show up in
the sequel eventually including melota
spawn gother Tristan Lancelot and many
more but at first the main hero we
follow is peral a new character who
seems to be a regular human but who is
actually something very different
personal is actually completely
different from all the beings we've met
in the series so far and that is why he
turns out to be so incredibly
overpowered if you're confused don't
worry I will explain it all in this this
video so stick around until the end for
the shocking twist you guys know how
this works if you enjoy our 7ly and forn
nights of apocalypse videos and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment for that YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help us hit
2 million subscribers here on the
channel do me a huge favor and subscribe
we're literally only a few hundred
subscribers away as I am recording this
video we could hit it any minute so
please do me a huge favor and subscribe
right now okay so the prophecy about the
four nights of the Apocalypse describes
the night of death as a boy with verdant
Wing likee hair that boy is perel who
has green wing-shaped hair and who looks
like he's about 10 even though he's
actually 16 I guess in that sense he is
quite similar to Motas the hero of the
original series peral spent the vast
majority of his life on top of a
gigantic pillar-shaped mountain called
God's finger he lived there with his
grandpa varges and there was no one else
up there with them they were essentially
completely isolated from the outside
world and that was very much intentional
peral's Grandpa was actually hiding
perel from the outside world and we'll
talk more about why later on in the
video God's finger is definitely an
interesting place to grow up it is so
tall that the tip is located above the
clouds and from the top of God's finger
you can actually see the shadow of Sky
Island which is the home of the
celestials from the prisoners of the sky
movie at first we were told that peral's
father was a Holy Knight of Camelot
named Ironside a man who betrayed King
Arthur along with person P's grandfather
and then disappear ironide disappeared
and P's Grandpa took him to God's finger
and raised him there alone P's Grandpa
would go on to train persal from the age
of three in order to turn him into an
extremely powerful fighter peral's calm
and peaceful existence is suddenly
shattered one day when his grandfather
is murdered at the hands of a knight in
red armor who showed up on God's finger
in a floating boat The Red Knight
fatally wounded vares and left peral for
dead but mirac ully persal survived and
as his grandpa is dying he tells persal
that The Red Knight is actually ironide
his father from that point onward perel
is determined to find ironide and punish
him for what he did to his grandpa he
also wants answers from his father about
the true circumstances of his birth and
about the real reason why IR inside
killed his grandpa and tried to kill
peral as well P's Grandpa's claim that
Ironside is PR's father is only kind of
true like it's not literally true but
but I will explain all of that later on
in the video so stick around after his
Grandpa's death peral finally leaves
God's finger for the first time because
he grew up in isolation persel is
extremely curious about the outside
world and since he has no experience
socializing with people other than his
grandpa he is initially excited by
everything and he is very naive and
trusting of strangers at certain times
this gets persal into serious trouble
but this pure and innocent outlook on
life also leads him to make some
incredible friends and allies our first
real hint that PR is something more than
an ordinary human is his extremely
unique Magic which is called hope hope
is a type of magic that is powered by
the hope of the user's allies and by the
faith that the user's allies place in
him it's like the author of the manga
took the idea of the power of friendship
and decided to turn it into an actual
magic power in that world hope is a very
rare type of magic and it is classified
as hero type magic this is a magic type
that only manifests incredibly rarely in
a very small number of people hope
allows persal to generate a magical Aura
around his body or parts of his body and
he can then manipulate this Aura in many
different ways the aura increases his
physical strength when he attacks it
allows him to defend himself by acting
as a shield and it also has the ability
to heal extremely serious injuries
almost instantly the AA can also change
shape depending on the situation that
pel is in for instance the AA can turn
into a weapon or it can take the shape
of a pair of wings and this allows pel
to literally fly persel is also able to
to channel his magic into real weapons
that he can then use himself and the
main weapon that he uses is actually
Dragon handle a fragment of the cofin of
Eternal darkness that Motas had used as
his own weapon back in the original
series so yeah there are definitely some
similarities between persal and Motas
the aura produced by peral's Magic has
the ability to absorb the magic attacks
of others and shoot them back at the
attacker and peral is also able to
create a bunch of Chibi Shadow clones
that have a will of their own and that
will do whatever they can to help p will
get out of even the tightest situations
the chibi Shadow clones also have the
power to heal injuries and this includes
the injuries of persal as well as the
injuries of his allies because peral's
magic has a will of its own it was even
able to literally resurrect persal and
bring him back to life after he was
outright killed by his enemies however
this ability to defy death only applies
to PC and so far he has not been able to
resurrect other people after they
already died even if he desperately
wanted to do it but P's power isn't all
light hope and friendship his magic also
possesses a darker side such as the
ability to instantly drain all the
fluids out of a living being just by
touching them essentially mummifying the
part of that person's body that person
will touched directly pral showcased
this power for the first time when he
was filled with despair because he
wrongly believed that his friends had
just been killed he essentially lost it
and went into a dangerous berserk mode
kind of like ass salt mode motus in the
original series normal healing magic
does not have the power to alter the
effects of this strange mummification
attack and only P's own hope magic can
reverse the mummification process after
personal finally comes to his senses in
addition to his unbelievably rare and
Powerful magic personal was always far
stronger and far more resistant to
damage than an ordinary human there was
always something different about persal
something special and almost superhuman
and that of course led to a lot of
speculation about peral's true race and
identity I mean he has enhanced
resistance against drugs and other types
of potions he has built in resistance to
the miasma of the demon realm he also
has an above average lung capacity due
in part to the fact that he grew up at a
very high altitude on top of God's
finger and although at first you might
be tempted to think that maybe PR's
extraordinary strength comes from the
fact that he got intense physical
training since he was 3 years old in the
end that is only a small part of the
story we eventually learned that persal
has the ability to speak the language of
the demon Clan although he doesn't even
know why he knows this language his
knowledge of the demon tongue on top of
his resistance to the miasma of the
demon realm led to a lot of people
speculating that personal might actually
be some sort of powerful demon but the
truth is even crazier than that because
persal turns out to be something else
entirely he speaks the demon language
because he spent some time in the demon
realm as a very young child but he is
actually a completely different being
from everything we've seen so far perel
is none other than a life spirit inside
a human body remember when I said that
Ironside was kind of pel's father but
not really well pel was born as the
seventh Prince of some unknown Kingdom
but he actually died as a baby when the
wagon he was traveling in fell off a
cliff ironide found the body of the
child and he took it to Camelot he then
used forbidden magic to turn the body
into a vessel for a powerful life Spirit
a life spirit is a being of pure energy
with no shape or personality and these
life Spirits are what make all life
possible including the lives of all the
races in that world life Spirits are
said to be pieces of the great one so I
guess we could think of them as like
pieces of God or something along those
lines now normally a life Spirit has no
personality or individuality so Ironside
wanted to use the life Spirit to bring
the deceased baby back to life and give
it what is essentially an immortal body
a human body that is possessed by a life
spirit will be virtually indestructible
and that is exactly what Ironside wanted
because his own biological son deodora
was sick and dying Ironside expected
that peral's body infused with the life
Spirit would become an empty vessel that
he can then transfer Theodora's Soul
into however after peral's body was
revived by the life Spirit persal
somehow gained self-awareness and
individuality it might have been because
veses showed love to him and refused to
allow him to Simply become a vessel for
someone else or it might have been a
combination of several factors but at
the end of the day ironside's plan
backfired The Vessel he created for his
son became a completely different person
the person we know today as peral a life
Spirit who inhabits a human body VES
then took peral and escaped with him in
order to protect him and prevent him
from becoming a vessel for ironside's
real son and that is why P's Grandpa
kept him on top of God's finger for so
long he was hiding peral away because he
didn't want his own unique personality
to be forcibly erased by Ironside in
order to make room for deodor as of the
making of this video even in the manga
we only got very little information
about life Spirits they appear to be a
powerful Magical Force of Nature and
normally they don't have a will or a
personality they just exist and they
they power all the life in the world
kind of like the sun peral is unique
because he is the first example of a
life spirit with a personality but
needless to say the power of a life
spirit is extremely mysterious and
unstable when all of P's little chibi
clones tapped into the hopes of all the
demons in the demon realm they were able
to fuse into a single normal-sized clone
of personal who is able to fight in
peral's place when he himself becomes
too tired this large clone is something
sometimes referred to as zarura and du
and he is a being of pure magical energy
that seems to be practically immune to
all forms of physical attack zarura and
D says that life Spirits have the
ability to use the hope of others to
spread life but they also have the
ability to use the despair of others to
spread death so again this power is very
unstable and although it can do a lot of
good it could also potentially do a lot
of horrible things if it gets out of
control personal is a way Ware of this
and he eventually comes to the
conclusion that if he keeps going on the
path that he is going right now he will
bring a terrible fate upon all of his
precious friends and comrades because of
this persal decides that an unnatural
creature like him shouldn't even exist
and he ultimately decides to abandon his
human vessel that said peral's body
remains alive even after the life Spirit
leaves it so you better believe that
persal will return eventually now you
know the shocking truth about persal the
night of death and his true identity but
are you wondering about the other three
Knights of the Apocalypse if so check
out my video that explains all four of
them and the prophecy itself link on
screen and in the description if you
guys enjoyed this video and you want to
see more seven deadly sins and fortn
nights of the apocalypse videos here on
the channel leave a quick like to let me
know and we are only a few hundred
subscribers away from 2 million do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now